[Music]  the new apple iphone 4s has been out uh  for for 10 days already this thing is a  huge hit and one of the most talked  about apps on the new iphone is the  voice activated personal assistant named  siri  and uh well apple has already jumped on  siri's popularity with a new ad it's  pretty cool take a look  we have a flat tire how do i tie a bow  tie again what's the fastest way to  hartford hospital yeah siri get me  reservations for 2 7 p.m between your  boobs do i need an umbrella in new york  this weekend remind me to call chris  when i get home what is the length of my  penis in miles remind me to get milk  when i leave work tell my wife i'm gonna  make it come on siri  wake me up at sex play some cold train  you please tell me the distance between  and  move my meeting from three to four how  far away am i right now from diarrhea  town  hey siri  [Applause]